We Begin this half hour with a unique
program that's improving the lives of
the young and old but uniting the two
generations Adriana Diaz has more
bye have a good day it's a typical
morning have a great day at the
preschool kindest creators
but inside
the math lessons are anything but
typical we like to say that we are
helping fight ageism one little baby at
a time
the school is inside a retirement
complex called Oak Park arms
the kids visit the seniors down the hall
how are you good and the seniors can pop
into preschool to help teach is she fun
to play with yeah yeah this program
helps with kids being more accepting of
older people and older people being more
accepting with kids running around again
the idea came from teachers and best
friends Pam Lawrence and Jamie Moran who
know the benefits I grew up with my
grandfather who had Alzheimer's disease
I remember that I was the only one he
remembered towards the end and that like
his I'm gonna tearing sorry like his
light his eyes would light up when I
woke up in the room yeah
it's therapeutic for Resident and
Grassley the mornings are not into great
shape and then I come down here and you
have to forget all that because you can
see why
you forget you go
realm they tell me so when the kids it
makes your day
it's Nancy Thornton and Mark Schwartz
say not seeing the preschool ERS during
coven
terrible
cheer you up
their little faces and their smiles you
missed them oh yes loneliness is a
killer it's been likened to smoking 15
cigarettes a day Donna butts runs
Generations United which promotes
intergenerational learning for older
adults they score better on memory tests
they're more physically able as well as
mentally able and children show
improvements in language math and social
skills how old are you today Sadie
[Music]
four seven
I know
that playful energy uplifts Lori Bell
it's rides me it motivates me and it
makes me believe in myself and it's a
good thing just these four-year-olds
do you hope that this is a model that's
repeated across the country I think this
is a way to help change our country
I always say love always wins this is
the definition of love so
spread it sprinkle it everywhere for CBS
Saturday morning Adriana Diaz Oak Park
Illinois
yes yes yes yes yes right love always
wins spread it everywhere sprinkle it
everywhere love Saves the World love
love love love love love
[Music]